in alphabetical order first of all we
have Suzy Davis
she's production designer on mr. Turner
and Eve Stewart is BAFTA nominated for
her production design on Vera Drake
Elizabeth the first the King's Speech
and the hour and finally Charlotte Watts
production designer on mr. Turner set
decorator sorry mr. Turner let's start
with mr. Turner both your work on it was
the aim with this film to recreate a
very accurate for the period or what
were Mike's intentions in discussing
with you both what he wanted with any
Mike Lee film your your accuracy is
important especially the period pieces
you know he expects it to be
historically correct but we're making a
cinematic dramatic story so we delve
into the research of the period and the
time and we had a historical research on
board very early on and the whole across
the board every department researches
that and get-get you sort of build a
subconscious backbone of that era and of
that history
but during prep you soon get to a point
where you sort of throw that away
because we're a production designers
we're not historical recreate errs and
what were the challenges or the biggest
challenges for both of you that triangle
time money and quality simple as that I
think once you've I think originally the
challenge is to work without a script
but once you delve in again
I found that Mike makes his movies that
way and he has done 20-plus movies that
way it works so I'm it's not up to me to
say well you can't do it like that you
have to join in and it is literally a
leap of faith you do at the beginning
you where are we going to go but it's a
fantastic journey because you are
absolutely involved in the discovery of
his story at the same time so that was
the initial challenge was going whoa
what you know what I've got a certain
amount of money a certain amount of time
and I've no idea what we're going to
in six months apart from knowing that it
was about Turner's the last 25 years
once you're over that then it is it gets
to be time money quality here and Eve
just stay with my tea for a moment but
you worked on the other two key period
Mike Lee films topsy-turvy and Vera
Drake yes did you feel such as naked
secrets and I was in Korea but just in
terms of the period but 70s oh I thought
was period I at the time but I think
what I can backsies yeah I mean but I
had a different journey and that I'd
been doing theatre with Mike before yeah
so when he asked me to do a film I
assumed that's how all the films were
made so I'm actually staggered when I
get a script so even now I'm working on
a family we've we still haven't got a
script Michou Monday you know we've
gotten a vague one by a completely agree
about the historical and period
vernacular you've got to research you've
got to know your period and although
you're not like doing a documentary
I still think you've got to hit key
notes with the complete accuracy I'm so
far now I think as long as you weave the
tapestry of believability and surround
everyone with they think they're in this
bubble of this world you can you can
take license and you can cheat and a lot
of that I'll do with Carlisle at
probably as you have and so you're kind
of you're creating a kind of movement of
color and but these key objects that you
must hit accurately what attracts the
three of you to a project just that not
dealing specifically with Mike here like
anyone else essentially sent a number of
scripts storytelling for me I mean in in
the ideal world I'd love to be able to
choose but I'm not I'm not not at that
stage but it's storytelling simple you
know it's a good script you're working
with I mean I can't say anyone I know
any designers I know I really has
Liberty to go I don't know how I'm not
touching it for it and be out of work
for you it doesn't work like that
anymore but um
I do think if you have to you can choose
and usually it will be the better story
and the ones that give you more license
to be creative yeah we want to
television for a moment with both of you
the distinction between working on film
and working on television do you feel
these days I've talked to some
cinematographers and they say the cinema
TV in many ways certain kinds of TV is
getting so close to cinema in the way
that they're looking at an image do you
feel the same from your point of view
you're wrong yeah I mean I think there's
definitely television wants the same
production value that films got and yeah
you've got to put the same amount of
detail in and it's you know you're still
the same person doing the same job
you're not going to change it because
it's film or TV but it's just the
schedules not a lot tighter essentially
you're making a two-hour film and some
television series you could be working
on could be 1012 episodes long yeah as
well I mean I just add to that this
morning I've been putting a I've been
doing a bit of television now going to
do this bill
I've been putting bed linen on a bed for
example and I've got a pillowcase for
Jota and someone's put that in and it's
it's fine it's a lovely pillowcase for
anything oh my god it's scary a 35-foot
pillowcase it's like washed across the
screen yeah that's when you panic and
that's that's my big difference I got
everything that legally so big and
everyone will stare at the blop you've
done wrong and the mistake on the
stitching so you've got to be ultra
careful and especially now on tape and
digital wear with 35-millimeter it's
soft and it's kind hide the cameras in
the duct you have to look at things like
magnifying glass in case you get
anything wrong so I think the pressures
are added to the three of you what do
you enjoy most of the whole process
collaborating with a bunch of creative
people and that I mean and having fun it
is we are so lucky to do what we do
it's having fun with a bunch of other
like-minded people now I get to meet
like amazing dealers who sort of really
passionate about all their you know what
they deal in beer sort of 18th century
sewing kill something like that so I
kind of go at the research yes the
research they just sort of you know go
to auction houses and then you know keep
chatting chatting chatting and I find
the person I want to and then you get
invited to their house or they shop and
I find that fantastic experience meeting
these people their lives and then get
the peace that you want and move it into
the film but it's great yeah fantastic
just creating new world it's like it's
like constantly painting constantly
drawing and like being a kid in a vase
of toys it's just brilliant and watching
people come with you on your journey and
and my best thing is when you've done
amazing seven people walking like a
let's go back right to start and I'm
just curious with each of you what made
you choose this profession was they do
you know have you seen a film was this
something it's something in the theatre
that sort of sparked your passion I was
obsessed with Powell and Pressburger yes
so I felt the system roof fan club and
they're only a couple boxes and a pair
of scissors I mean that's all I ever did
as a kid was just make rooms of rooms so
much so that yeah I had to sleep on the
sofa
because I had covered my bedroom in sort
of room so progression I started work as
um I just needed to earn some cash was
looking for a grown-up job and I work
for a sculptor I started sweeping his
floors and making cups of tea and it was
as if someone had just opened a door
that I knew nothing about and he
sculpted polystyrene for films and
commercials and we'd make amazing
50-foot dragons and caves and all sorts
of things and I would go on set and we'd
go on the pre-light and I've watched
every one set everything up and it's a
brilliant opportunity for me to go hang
on a minute you can you can have a
career doing this can you and it just it
just yeah literally I remember the day
when I just thought I think
think I might have found what I want to
do yeah and then for that I think
Holloway Holloway Road Odeon aged seven
with my name watching Mary Poppins with
that key Laura stuff and then the film
and then because I'm so old they had
they said they had an interval with
everyone playing the organ
and then it I screamed apparently for 15
minutes and started again says the joy
of being in there in that space with
pictures and stories and escaping from
real life just for a minute it's not
necessarily movies that you you refer
back to but are there things that you
hop see Tobey is like yeah I think it's
a standout and yeah also David Lean's
were anything I mean gosh Lawrence of
Arabia remastered the other I just I was
just so blown away and even I knew that
they'd sweat a sand as a ridge in the
sand for like a mile so that your are a
grown up the screen and that's just
where the camel came over the horizon I
love that sort of thing and on that
moving note please
you
you
you